القدماء كود يطبخ على ضوء زين او قدر كاتم
كبسه حاشي الشباب
ويضيع
اما القدامى اللي من سني لا تلقى عنده قدر
له 22 سنه وفراش نوم عنده 17 سنه
[موسيقى]
يلا حيهم ضيفنا اليوم عبد الرحمن السنيدي
مؤسس سنيدر للرحلات واتوقع كثير منكم سبق
وتعامل مع السنيدي او المحلات المشابهه
بهالفتره من السنه مع الجو الزين والطلعات
والكشتات والهاي كينج وغيره بنسولف مع
ضيفنا اليوم عن عده امور تخص هالنوع من
البزنس مثل كيف تجيهم افكار المنتجات
ويصممونها ويصنعونها بناء على احتياجات
الناس كيف تؤثر شغلهم مع اختلاف نوعيه
العملاء مع الوقت يعني واختلاف اتهاماتهم
مثلا صار في اقبال اكبر من النساء على
المنتجات ونشاطات جديده مثل
سابقا وش وضع البزنس باقي السنه اذا صار
الجو حار وما يشجع الطلعات امور كثيره
بنغطيها في حلقه اليوم نبداها مع تجربه
الضيف السابقه في البزنس وكيف تطور سنيدي
من محل في بريده للخياطه الخيام ومستلزمات
البر الى بزنس يخدم الناس بمنتجات متنوعه
مع قائده عملاء كبيره سواء كان في
السعوديه او في الخليج فاترككم الان مع
الحلقه حياك الله ابو حمد يا هلا ومرحبا
نورتنا اليوم الله يحييك
طبعا قبل لكن قبلها كلمني منتج حق
البرنامج الحلقه يقول اسالوا عن مدير
المدرسه
ما ادري وش اللي صار بينك
قديم عام 1400 تقريبا و11
[موسيقى]
كنت شاب صغير البزنس عائلي طبعا
ايه فكنت بجيب بطلع سجل تجاري واجيب عماله
[موسيقى]
ولازم يكون وقته ان
البطاقه تكون متسبب لانه في طالب متسبب
طالب ما يقدر
علشان لازم اجيب ورقه من المدرسه افصل من
المدرسه واجيب ورقه اني غير
طالب رحت للمدير المدرسه ودخلت عليه فقلت
له ابغى ورقه
[موسيقى]
للاحوال المدنيه
لكي اعدل من طالب طالبي
قال
ما انت طالب ايه ورقه
فجلس قاعد ينصح ان التعليم كم كان عمرك
يمكن
اي مرحله كانت تقريبا ثالث ثانوي وثاني
ثانوي ما قدر يقنعان جاي مصر
بالنهايه بعد جلست عنده حدود اربعين دقيقه
عطانا الورق وعلى طول من المدرسه
للاحوال المدنيه بس ما فصلت
لا هذا لازم
خلاص اني ليس طالب الحين حلو خلاص انتهيت
تركتها ايه حب حب للتجاره لين عائله
تجاريه حنا
أكبر كان مدرس
ابراهيم يعني محمد وابراهيم مسلم لكن انا
اللي عندي الشغف بالشيء هذا
حماس اوجد على راسك
طبعا
راحت السنين وبعد مرور يمكن 23 سنه
مدير المدرسه متقاعد
وهو ضمن مجموعه من
ساتذه ودكاتره
ومعنيين جروب
بالبلد
انه شركه السنيدي ذي اللي لها دور اجتماعي
لازم تكرر
اجتهادا منهم
وصلحوا درع وتواصلوا معي بعض الاشخاص من
مجموعه
وجوكر الشركه
وقدموا شكروا جهود الشركه
جهودها الاجتماعيه
فبالصدفه كان معاهم هو اكبر سنا هو اللي
لازم يقدم الدرع فكان جالسين واقفين
مجموعه حوالي يمكن عشرين او 15 ماذكر
للتكريم وكان هو اللي يقدم لي
الدرع
وهو يقدمه تذكره 22 سنه قبل لما جالس
يقنعني اني اظل بالتعليم تكلمت عن موضوع
ما كلمته يمكن يشوف الحلبيه
لكن استاذ فاضل
ومربي اجيال بس وقتها خلنا نرجع للمرحله
اللي بدا فيها الوالد البزنس وايش كانت
الفكره في البدايه الوالد كان من الناس
الاوائل اللي رحلوا للرياض
من المدن الصغيره الى الرياض كانت هي يعني
مقصد الشباب قبل سبعين سنه للعمل
فبدا
اعمال مهنيه وانتهت بالخياطه سنه المكائن
الخياطه ما في كهرب على الرجل ماكينه ميب
كهربائيه
ثم انتقل الى بعده الى بريده عام تقريبا
1385 تقريبا او اثنين هجري
واشتغلوا معها اخواني محمد
بدا بالرياض وانت ببريده
اخواني اكبر مني كانوا يشتغلون مع الوالد
تعرف كم بالسابق شغل يدوي كله خياطه
الحج كانت بسيطه
احتياجاتها الباديه خزانات الراويه الماء
يحطونه بالددسن
كانت اشياء بسيطه وقتها
استمرت الامور
حتى اللي هو بدا العمل الاحترافي اليوم
اطلع سجل تجاري عمل
و411
انا شاب وعندي حماس
وانا اصلا من يومنا صغير وانا احب
البيع
في اشياء ثانيه يمكن ما قال اهلك ايوه كنت
اداره التعليم كانت تصرف شيء اسمه تغذيه
اللي هو تغذيه تصرف للطلاب جلس اربع سنوات
ويسرع انا التحقت بالتعليم قبل ما ينقطع
بسنتين او ثلاث سنوات او سنتين
فكان
التغذيه ذي
اخذها
ولا كلها بالمدرسه لما اطلع
اجمعها وابيعها بريالين ايوه بالحاره
مثلا تلقان
اي ايام اجازه
وخميس كان الاجازه الخميس او جمعه
اروح مع الوالد
السوق ببريده ومن اروح اشتري خمسه ريال او
ثلاثه ريال جرائد الجريده بنص
اقعد بالشارع ابيعها
ابيعه ريال في الربح مئه بالمئه كانت طبعا
هذا حنا عائله التجاريه
العائله له دور
تاخذه ابنائه ومصارين
السوق الاب ياخذوا ولده
للدكان من اول يسمونه
فيتشبع بالمهنه دي ويطلع عليها الحين كثير
من رجال الاعمال اللي نجحوا امتداد هالشيء
يعودون
بدري بعد فتره
يتصلح سياكل الحاره ايوه
فمثلا السيكل خربان جنزير منفليكس رقعه
بالبيت فاتح معي عده واللي يخرب سيكل
وهصلحه
صلحه بعشره ريال 15 ريال
طبعا المنافسه مهمه فاذكر طلع لي منافس
الحارس يصلح
فنزل السعر
وجهت له تهديد تعرف صغيرين
بعدين
دقيته يعني ضربته عشان العصابات
وش اللي يصير الحين البزنس والشركات الحين
المنافسه بس ان هذه منافسه
دقيته الصباح هو العصر قاعدين نلعب انا
وياه
فرفع الاسعار بعده
للتجاره مع الوالد وقتها طبعا زي ما قلت
لك اخواني قبل اكبر من يشتغلون مع الوالد
حلو
ويعرفون المهنه الخياطه
ودخلت معكم الاشرعه تفصيل للسيارات الواني
على نفس الخط هذا صغير
ياخذون المحل واشتغل معهم بالمحل وايش
اللي بدا يشكل بشكل سنيدي اللي نعرفه
اليوم تعرف دائما الشاب الصغير عنده حماس
اكثر من الكبير
فكان عندي طموح
وطلعت السجل التجاري وجبت عماله
واهتميت بالخياطه
وبدا بكوره الانتاج تتوسع حلو
طبعا لمين فتره من الفترات
صار فيه طلب
على الخياطه بشكل اكبر
فاستدعى نجيب عماله اكثر
واحنا
كاخوان نشتغل مع بعض الوالد عاد بعدين
خلاص مخلص شغل من ذلك الوقت يعني من عام
1410 وقبل خلينا حلو الله يرحمه
فبدات الباكوره
تطور تطوير المنتجات
يعني عام وشو خلاكم تقولون بنتخصص الحين
بلوزر الرحلات
من الخياطه الى الشعر وقته
كانت موضه الناس تحط بيوت شعر
فهي اغتنام الفرص وقتها
الشعر كانت اول ما بدات
فهي فرص فاغتنام الفرصه بدانا بعمل
بيوت الشعر حلو
وتطور المجال هذا
بعدين
صار فيه يجي طلبات احتياج للناس اللي تطلع
للبر
من اول الواحد اللي يبغى يطلع للبر ياخذ
بطانيه وفراش ومربوطن بحبل
وياخذ اغراضه بكرتون
فطلعنا اللي هو
النوم
خياطه محليه قماش ثقيل عن الماء
بعده بدينا بالشنط بدل الواحد ما ياخذ
كرتون شنطه قماش
بعد بدات الفكره كيف اجاب منتجات
تناسب بيئه
عام 97
ميلادي
صار عندي طموح
واخواني ما قصروا وعطونا الضوء الاخضر
رجعوني يشجعوني بشكل كبير
رحت لامريكا مع احد الزملاء
كان دارس من هناك درس هناك محمد الخميس
الله يذكره بالخير
فجمعنا داتا
الاكثر من ست شركات امريكيه
بعده ولايات
والرحله استمرت تذكر فوق ال25 يوم او شهر
البيانات
من الملحقيه التجاريه الامريكيه وش كنت
النبي شركات
تبيع لوازم مره رحلات
لما طلعت هناك
جلست مريت كل الشركات
تبادر الى وانا بالعوده طبعا تم جلب بعض
من شركه من الشركات بضاعه
لكنها ما هي مناسبه لبيئتنا
كنت رايح تدور منتجات
بستورد لانه حنا مشكله بلدنا
لما جاء
النفطرد بنطلع على الموضوع البزنس عموما
لما جاء النفط
استوردنا كل شيء
السعوديه استوردت استوردت المهندسين
استوردت البضائع استوردت فجبنا ثقافات من
برا
صارت هي اللي متاحفنا الحين هذه ما لها
علاقه لكن يتكلم فيها
تلقى الحين المتحف فيه ماكينه خياطه هنديه
مروحه هنديه
كرتون بيبسي هذا
دخيل بسبب النفط انتجت في الثور
[موسيقى]
وعد من هذه الشيء عاد الرؤيه اليوم
نظرت للشهاده وفي امريكا بدل ما تروح
انه لقيت كل شيء مكتوب عليه
طيب وش الفرق اني مصير مثل الشركات ذي
والنوعيه الظاهر انها تختلف حتى ما تختم
كنا واحد شاب صغير رايح بيقلد شركات
العملاقه دي بس لا الطموح
فبعده بدات الفكره انه كيف اجيب منتجات
لان جبت المنتجات في ما تناسب مع بيئتنا
تناسب البيئه الغابات الانهار
يعني السلع
المصنعه ذي ما تناسب بيئتنا
بيئتنا صحراويه
شمس
لازم سلعه تتحمل البيئه بالحراره مثلا
الحراره لكن المنتجات مصنعه للغابات خيام
بلاستيك للغابات
للانهار طريقه جلوسهم طريقه طهيهم
معدات تناسب الاوروبيين وامريكان
بدات فكره اني كيف نصنع لان الاصل ان احنا
نخيط هي القاعده ان احنا نخيط ونشتغل
فرحت وجبت اشياء جاهزه لقيت لا ممكن نفس
اللي نطور منتجات اللي احنا نخيطها او
نشتغل او نطولها بالمحل طلعت
انه في البدايه كنت تخيطون المنتجات انكم
ما العلاقه في توجهكم الان بعدين بدها
تطورهم منتجات تخيطونها برضو لانكم
تتوسعون منتجات اللي ما تقدرون
فحاولت اني اطلع الصين كانت الرحله صعبه
وقتها لاول مره كانت كنت تطلع منها تعرف
من القصيم للرياض انا بالقصيم ومن الرياض
للبحرين ومن البحرين الهونج كونج وبعدين
من هونج كونج الى
داخل الصين تاخذ يوم ونص طيب العمله اخذت
وقتها شيكات سياحيه اخذت دولارات واخذت
بطاقه فيزا وقتها انا ما ادري في واجهه
جهز كلش
بعد يمكن قبل قبل عمل الالفين اذا ما في
شيء رحلات مباشره من الرياض لا خلاص الحين
في مباشر ثمان ساعات وانت هناك
وكان راحتك
فبعد المحاولات الخاطئه والمشاكل
والدروبات بالموضوع
والخسائر ويضحك عليك
ابي اجيب عدد وادوات
للبرد
هذا الحين
جاهزة ونصنعه ومن القبيل فجلس الموضوع
يترنح حوالي ثلاث سنوات
لمين عاد بعد كذا بدت
تستقر الامور
وجلسنا بعد خمس سنوات
ثلاث سنوات وبعدين خمس سنوات فبدا تطوير
منتوجات
صديقه للبيئه عندنا
تناسب مع عاداتنا وتقاليدنا
وبيئتنا
بدينا نطور منتوجات وايش اول منتجات
تطورونا اللي كان عليها اكثر طلب وقتها
هنا بدينا نطورها حنا بنخيطها بايدينا
ونوديها هناك
ونصنعها بطريقه احترافيه عشان الكلفه تكون
اقل وبجوده عاليه فانتخيطها كنموذج اولي
اي لازم نصنع العينه هنا سواء معدنيه او
كهربائيه او نصنعها هنا وبعدين نطلع تقول
له
لازم تشرف عليهم ولازم حلو فاول المنتجات
وش اللي كانت طبعا الشنط ومش الشنط هذه
البدايات
كفايه
هم من الخيام وهم من بعد كذا
ما تخص الطبخ وما يخص الطهي
[موسيقى]
في عصر رقمي متغير باستمرار المواكبه هي
اساس النجاح ولاننا رواد المستقبل الرقمي
نوظف خبراتنا وقدرتنا لنمكن نبتكر نبدع في
تبني احدث التقنيات وتوفير الحلول بكفاءه
وذكاء
[موسيقى]
وش اللي كان يرشدكم للمنتج التالي اللي
تحتاجون تطورونا طبعا المستهلك
لها الدور الكبير
بعلم التسويق الحين جلست السوق تتسمى
حاليا
يعني
نتلمستهلك
مثلا جاك خمسه اشخاص طلبوا عزبه بشكل معين
ولا بسعر معينه هل تقول خلاص لازم الحين
نطورها
من جانبيه
حنا
نطلع للبر ونشوف ايش احتياجاتنا والمستهلك
نفسه لما يجي
وياخذ منتج ويجيك يقول لك لا ابغى اقول له
تعديل لان عندنا خياطه وعندنا حداده
وعندنا
ترهين بعض السلع وقته
فالمستهلك يرشدنا
فالنصل الى منتجات متطوره
للبيئه او البيئتنا فتحديثكم للمنتج
التالي للطورون ومن تجربتكم الشخصيه ومن
الطلبات
تطور موضوعي لانه يجينا افكار
يعني او تطوير منتجات من العملاء وناخذها
مقابل مبلغ مالي
بجمعك على المفصل اكثر في موضوع تطوير
المنتجات بس قبله ودي اعرف يعني الخط
الزمني نكمله بس الين ما وصلتوا اليوم هذا
الكلام اللي ذكرته رحلتك للصين تطوير
منتجات كله كان خلال عملكم في بريده فقط
متى توسعتو وانتقلتوا للرياض بدات طبعا
بدل الموضوع بيع الجمله او المحلات صار
بدات تظهر محلات الرحلات محلات صغيره
لانه احتياج السوق يجيك يجي ناس يدخلون
بيلبي احتياج منطقه مختلفه
مثلا بحايل او بالرياض او الدمام او مناطق
ثانيه
يجون ياخذون من عندنا
الكميات على درزا على نص درزن وقته مئه
بسيطه ويفتح الواحد محل ما يكلفه يمكن
وقته خمسين الف ريال
بعض المحلات صارت عملاقه الان خلال عشرين
سنه
سؤالك انت تقول كيف طلعت من المنطقه
وتصيرون متواجدين في عام 2009 بدات
الخروج من المنطقه
بدينا بالرياض فرع واحد وبعدين فرع ثاني
ثم بعد كذا
حفر الباطن خميس مشيط
وجده
وبالنهايه الان في متجر الكتروني حلو يكون
يغطي المنطقه كامل
طبعا عندنا قطاع جمله
حدا ما زال شغال ويخدم العملاء
يعني فيه خدمه ما بعد البيع للعملاء من
ضمانات من اللي ما يمشي عنده يرجع خلاف وش
الانواع المنتجات اللي تطورونها وتبيعونها
للناس
دخلنا بعده مجالات كثيره ما هو بس
[موسيقى]
يعني ما يخص السياره وتجهيز السياره ما
يخص
ما يخص الباربكيو الان الشواء ما يخص
الطهي ما يخص الغازات وخلافه ما يخص الشنط
والخيام
الفرش النوم البسط كراسي المرتفعه الكراسي
الارضيه
دخلنا بالالوان
المنتجات بظل الرؤيه
وتوجه الدوله
خلال السنوات الماضيه
تاثير خطى العرب اللي هو برنامج ثقافي
من اهم البرامج السعوديه
قدح فكره دكتور عيد اليحيى انه نجيب
منتجات تكون
حاكي بيئتنا
اجبناها بالمنتجات
جبناها للسوق زي القطه العسيري زي النقش
النجدي للمنتجات
بالسابق كان يجيك
ما يسمونه الغبار نقش موجود من نيوزلافيا
نقش خاص بيئتهم
طورت التصاميم بحيث
من من الثقافه المحليه اللي هو من تعرف
بلدنا مترامي الاطراف من عسير من
نجد من الحجاز وهكذا
المنتجات اللي يدخل موقعكم الالكتروني
المنتجات بدون مهيئه لموسم واحد في السنه
فهل انتم تبيعون على مدى السنه بنفس اتصور
الشتاء مثلا
تختلف لكن كل موسم من له معدات معينه
اتصور طبعا
الوقت خلنا نقول الشتاء والربيع ويمكن من
هو الراس لكن
تنوعت يعني من عندك الجنوب جنوب السعوديه
ومصايفنا تشتغل بالصيف
وفيها مختلف
التضاريس مختلف
اختلاف الطقس
فيشتغل عندنا اللي هو ما يخص الصيف الناس
تطلع للحدائق
او تطلع للمناطق البارده بالجنوب او
طلعاتهم تكون ليليه فيحتاجون معدات تناسب
ليليه طلعت الليليه بالنهار الجو مشمس
وحار فالناس تبدا تطلع بالليل
له معدات هذه طورنا لها معدات كثيره
فدائما عندنا تطوير للمعدات اللي تناسب مع
المناطق وكذلك تناسب مع الاوقات
والمواسم موسم الصيف موسم رمضان رمضان
يكون له معدات اللي هي الجلسات
الخارجيه
ما يسمونه
للسمار الناس تجلس بالهواء الطلق فيحتاجون
جلسات معدات
متنوعين بالعدد والادوات بحيث انه تخدم
جميع الشرائح
كذلك السيارات
احتياج السياره سواء بالصيف لا احتياج
اللي بيسافرون بالطرق لهم احتياجات
شمسات او
اماكن الاكواب او
غطاء القير ثم اداء الخروج او الطبق يسمى
الخلف للسياره وشنطه العفش فيها اكثر من
500 منتج هذه تخص بس السياره
والرحله الصيفيه حلف المنتجات اللي تبيع
واللي تمشي تتغير حسب الموسم وحسب الوقت
وحسب لازم تتغير حسب الموسم والوقت
وكذلك الافتكار المنتجات مستمر عندنا
كيف يؤثر على الموضوع على عمليه التصنيع
والتسويق والاستيراد والتشغيل بشكل عام
عندكم في الشركه يعني هل انك مثلا تقول
اني بصنع من الشتاء من السنه اللي قبلها
وبعدين ببدا اصنع منتجات الصيف طبعا
يعني ليبدا ابتكار المنتج ومن ثم
استخراج العينه الاولى ثم
الموافقه هم عاد يبدا بعد كذا انتاجه هذا
قصدي عشان ما وضحت سؤالي اتصور المخزون
لبيع ما هو بواحد انك تضطر تغير في
المخزون بشكل مستمر يستمر
يقعد معك لنهايه السنه
تصنيع المنتجات
الاستيراد الكميات الكبيره او تصنيع كميه
الكبيره وضريبته اللي هو السكات يعني يصير
عندك دروبات
زون زايد
خسائر بالموضوع ده بسبب الموسميه
الموسميه او اختلاف اذواق الناس او اختلاف
عادات وتقاليد الناس قاعده باللون الاخير
تختلف اذواقهم الناس وتختلف احتياجاتهم
بشكل كبير في تسارعه لسبع سنوات الاخيره
هذه هذه المواسم فالمناطق برضو نفس الشيء
المناطق نعم تصور اللي يبيع يعني
المناطق الجنوبيه الشماليه
فتره
الفتره البراده والشتاء والبرادي نقول مده
طويله
او تبوك
المناطق الجنوبيه زي ود الدواسر او الرياض
فتره الشتاء اقل بس هل الاشياء اللي
اشتغلنا في الشتاء هالمنطقتين نفس الشيء
لا يختلف وش الاختلاف يعني طريقه جلوسهم
مثلا مناطق الرياض تلقى يجلسون على كراسي
او مرتادين من دول الخليج
يجوني
سياراتهم
يعني تسوقوا هنا
فروع الرياض او الحفر او اي منطقه قبل شوي
الناس تغيروا لاحظته في السنوات الماضيه
في العميل اللي يشكل طبعا بالنسبه لاكبر
ايوه العميل يختلف لانه
طلع جيل جديد
ثقافته مختلفه عن الاجيال السابقه اللي من
سني
احتياجنا حنا من سني وحوليه مختلف عن جيل
الشباب اللي طلع برا ودرس برا او
يعمل الحين بشركات
استخدمت تقنيه
صارت يختلف
طريقه الطهيه
الشواء الحين القدماء كود يطبخ على ضوء
زين او قدر كاتم كبسه حاشي الشباب على
خيال الجددون حاجات اسرع كيوت
بس تحب
العميل ذا هو اللي من احسن شيء
هذا ياخذ يشتري كلمه طلع البر اشترى ويضيع
اما القدامى اللي من سني لا تقع عنده قدر
له 22 سنه
وفراش نوم وعنده 17 سنه
لازم نسكر لا صار عميلنا كده
النساء لها
الحدائق وطلعته
الاستراحات
جعل فيه
استهلاك مختلف عن السابع الترندات الجديده
ذي حقت
ثقافه المشي هذه
والرياضه له دور
باختلاف المستهلك على السوق
كله سواء عندنا او بالسوق كله عموما قاعد
يختلف وتطوير المنتجات طورته شيء للنساء
طبعا ضروري
طلبات النساء لها احتياجات الوان خاصه
مثلا او احتياج خاص او يكون
تطوير منتجات معينه
فناخذها
منتج معين يناسب النساء اكثر من الرجال
للرحلات او
دائما المراه تبيع الحاجه الخفيفه شنطه
صغيره اللي ابريق ملون ودله ملونه في
يواجه وعقد لمبات رومانسي
وجالسه خفيفه لان المراه تبي حاجه
رومانسيه
الرجل اخشن شوي فلو معدات خاصه
اما
الرجل القديم لا هذا عاد
بمعدات مختلفه
ما معه الا قدر
وملعقه
زين وسكين
ويطبخ على طول انت بتبيع عليه عشرين شغله
هذا ما نستفيد منه
الشباب الاخير يجي يشتري عشرين قطعه ولا
يستخدم الا خمس قطع ما يعرف يستخدم
الباقيات
على كذا يعني
تستهدف تسويق
ويركز على الاحتياجات
شوفوا
هو اللي يتحكم فيك وليس انت اللي تحكم فيه
احنا نتبع توجه المستهلك
ودي ارجع نقطه الاجراءات حق التصنيع الان
جت بالكم فكره منتج معين ايا كان المتجاده
ممكن تضرب لي مثال على منتج من بدايته الى
الى مستوى
مثلا مشكله مثلا الناس تعاني من مشكله
البيانات وشلون يحافظها وتكسر
فسوينا لها
جرابات معينه
لحفظ الكاسات
عندنا فريق الان للتصميم حلو
البيانات
او اخواني عندهم خبره كبيره
قاعدين حنا ما زلنا
المطبخ
الداخلي عندنا حلو وبعد ما تخلصون تصميم
ترسلونه
للمصنعيتهم ايوه نعم وكيف تاكدون انه فعلا
المناسب للناس هل فقط من خلال المبيعات
ولا في لا لا بدي يختبر المنتج
وتهتم بالجوده اليوم اهم شيء الجوده جوده
المنتج
وخدمه العميل ما بعد البيع هذه مهمه جدا
بس كيف تسمع منه بعد
منه كميات بس ما تدري ايش راي الناس فيه
تتجمع الاراء
الفروع من خلال التعليقات بالتواصل
الاجتماعي من خلال
استقصاء منتج مع الجمهور هذه كلها عوامل
وش ابرز المشاكل
سواء في التصميم او التصنيع يعني تصمم
منتج تعتقد انه ممكن يلاقي رواج
تجد انه
ما عليه رواج وش كان الخطا يعني
هذه ما تقدر تحكمها هي قبول المستهلك له
طويله منتجات يعني اذا طورنا مثلا مئه
منتج
ينجح 90 منتج او 80 منتج
في نسبه منتجات ثابته دائما تفشل عندكم
ضروري اذا كنت تبي تقود السوق تقود الازم
يصير عندك فشل واتوقع العكس انه ممكن
تصممت منتج تتوقع انه يكون شيء جانبي وضرب
معك
بس اذا حققت نسبه 80% ممتاز 90% نجاح من
المنتجات بس انت تكون حاسب حسابك الماليه
من قبل انه هذه النسبه يعني غالبا بتفشل
خلي الاسنان جايه ضروري
زي ما قلت كود السوق
بتكون انت المفتكر بالسوق للمنتجات
والسوق يعني اصلا
لا يوجد له تجربه سابقه مو والله في سلع
مجيوبه من برا وتقلد عليها يعني زي
المنتجات
اللي جاب الكهربائي وكذا تروح تقلد عليها
منتجات الشركه عندنا كلها مبتكره
فهذه لها ضريبتها وش لخلك ما تبغى تصير
وكيل شركات
جاهزه
اغلب يعني تكون
تحت رحمه الشركات هذه
فلا انا اكون
انا البراند
شو انا اروح اسوق البراند
اصنع براند والحين نشوف ما شاء الله صنع
صناعه براند بالتغذيه عندنا شركات عملاقه
زي هرفي او كودو او خلافه او كيان او
مجموعه
علامات محليه نجحت فقط العشرات او المئات
الان جميع المجالات ليه نظل نستهلك
براندات عالميه لما نصدر حنا براندات على
التصديره اشتغلتوا على الموضوع هذا ولا
انتم مصدرون منتجات فيها عده منتجات
منتجاتنا مطلوبه دول الخليج
الدول العربيه بسراد مثلا
رسمي
افراد نعم موزعين فانت
تبيعها تصدر الموزعين موزعين
البيع
نعملهم فيه عملاء يطلبون
او ياتون للفروع لانها تعرف الرؤيه صارت
السعوديه مقصد سياحي لدول الخليج فتجد
العمانيين الاماراتيين والحين بدينا
نشوفهم كثره بالسعوديه
فصار فيه يعني اعاده بيع
عليهم هذولا وش غير لكم المتجر الالكتروني
في البزنس مؤخرا بدينا مؤخرا
في شريحه تحتاج تبي الخدمه دي
وفي شريحه لا يحب انه يجي يتسوق القطعه
يمسكها
ذهنيه
من الموقع
لا الاغلبيه يحبوا التسوق
زي سلعنا يحب الزبون يجي يتسوق ويجي يناظر
القطعه من التجربه
من منتج والله معروف على طول يشتريه يعرفه
سابقا
زي الوجبات
معين من العملاء اللي يتوجه غالبا سواء
اللي يعرف المنتج او عميل اصلا للمحل
العمله المتكررين هو اللي يطلب اللي
يضيعون زين فهو
عندكم برضو تجاره بالتصنيع المحلي غير
اللي تصنعونه برا نعم وشو بالضبط
محليا بعض المنتجات
من ابرزها الحين يعني ما يسمى الشذوذ اللي
هي للسيارات او
سياره او
شد يسمى على السياره يستخدم للبر ويكون
فيه الثلاجه يصير فيها اناره يصير فيها
خزان الماء يصير فيه مطبخ ومتحرك مكان
الالغاز مكان للقدر الكاتب مكان محول
الكهرباء
ايه اللي هي نقدر نقول تجهيز المركبات
تجهيز السيارات
وهذه له شريحه يكون طبقه طبقه عاليه شوي
مقتدرين هذه يجيب لي السياره
دخلنا عندنا بالمصنع نشتغل عليها بعد فتره
يستلمها ينطلق الى البر مكمله من الالف
الى الياء مكلفه عاده يعني الواحد يجيب
سياره قيمته 200 300 الف
وبعد كذا يسوي عليها
الشراع هذا او الكبينه الخلفيه
حقتهم
نعرض عليها مقترحات وافكار نسوي له
التصميم
يشوف صور نماذج صور
يوقع اتفاقيه خلال من خمسه ايام عشره ايام
عشرين يوم شهر يستلم
زي ما قلت سابق انا احتياجات السوق لازم
تتوجع حسب احتياجات السوق وثقافه المستهلك
يعني حنا بلدنا تتميز بتضاريس
واماكن جميله
فالناس تبغى تطلع للبر مو
الصيف وجميع المواسم
وبحكم اتساع رقعه السعوديه
الناس تحتاج السفر من منطقه لمنطقه اكتشاف
مواقع اثريه او
متنزهات او فيحتاجون تجهيز المركبه هذه
للمعدات بطريقه
تخلي تريحوا بالرحله
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
بس شيء زي كذا متخصص جدا وحرفي وطالبا في
مخاطره حتى عاليه في تعديل المركبات وشلون
وشلون بديتوا من وين جبت الناس هذول اللي
اشترون على تعديل المركبات
هي الاصل الشغله الاساسيه لو رجعنا للوراء
كانوا سيارات قبل ما تجي السيارات الجمس
عليها شراع من الخلف اللي كانوا يروحوا
يودون الطلاب وقتها المدارس او الركاب او
للحج لو شفت صور للحج قديمه تبي تشوف
الفروت القديمه عليها شراع من الخلف
هي منطلقها
فتطورت الى ما يسمونه العقرب
الشد السياره هم من عاد بعد كذا
التطور مستمر عليها مستمر لا يقف
المنافسه هو تعطونا منتجات تلقى
التطور مستمر هذا
وبناخذ تشكيله الفريق اللي اشتغلنا على
تعديل السياره نتصور يمكن في حداده
مصمم يمكن في مصمم في حداد في خياط فيه
كهربائي
هذه كلها لازم يكون عندك فريق متكامل واذا
ضحكتوا في مشاكل
سابقا عدلتوا اشياء طلعت او صممت واشياء
تنفيذها طبعا في مشاكل
انك تضمن للعميل
كل ما يترتب على الموضوع
ولو بعد استخدام صار عنده مشكله
جوده المنتج مهم والضمان والمصلحه فعلا
مصنع ولا ورشه ولا
مصنع صغير طبعا ليس
معنى المصانع الضخمه بخط انتاج لانه هذا
تصنيع خاص يعتبر هو يعني بس تنفذون في
التعديلات هذه ولا في شيء يصنع فيه غير
كونك السيارات الالمنيوم
اول ادراج هذه اللي فيها غاز وفيها مغسله
بس هذه كلها يدويه
طبعا
لازم معدات الضخمه ذي للقاص والطاج وخلاف
حلو بس
يكون عندك خط انتاجي لمنتج معين تنتج منه
الاف
هذا محتاج لكن طلبات خاصه
في موضوع الرؤيه
اكيد مش تحديدا
متوجهه جميع القطاعات انا اشوف لها مستقبل
زاهر بلدنا متوجه لك بيصير من افضل
الاقتصادات بالعالم باذن الله تعالى
المنافسين ما جبنا طاريهم طبعا المنافسه
هل انتم الان تعتبرون نفسكم الاكبر في
السوق طبعا تعتبر الاكبر والقائد للمجال
هذا والمطور المنتجات
ويوجد منافسه والمنافسه
صحيه للبزنس مهمه جدا المنافسه ايجابيه
على الاطراف كلها على المتنافسين ترقى
بخدمه العميل ترقب المنتج ترقى
بتطوير المنتجات فتحصل السوق السعودي بسبب
المنافسه صارت قياده
الناس اتصور
خدمته مثلا بيتوجه غالبا لكم
التنافس يخلق سوق زياده استهلاك
فالجميع يستفيد
تنافس
الجميل فيه انه
يخلق سوق
لا يقلل المبيعاتك لا يرفع مبيعات الجميع
تنافس
في مصنعين في مستوردين في
مطورين
لكن احنا بحكم اقدمتنا بالسوق
نقود السوق
بالمجال هذا
لكن ارجع واقول انه المنافسه الصحيه جدا
لجميع قطعتها تجاريه
والمنافسه بالمجال ده ترفع
الاستهلاك او القوه الشرائيه للاطراف كلها
حلو ولا اتوقع انك حددت احد بالضرب
بس السيكل وكس علي ربما حلو طيب في ذكرت
في ذات الحلقه موضوع الحوكمه اللي
اشتغلتوا عليه
وش في شيء تعتقد ممكن اصحاب الشركات
العاليه
طبعا سواء من مشاكل سواء من تحدي جميع
الشركات العائليه اذا لم
تروح للحوكمه نهايتها
يعني
تنتهي ما في شركه مؤسسه فرديه او عائليه
ظلت بطريقه بدون حوكمه الا تنتهي
وهذي شواهد كثيره بالبلد عندنا وزاره
التجاره والدوله حريصه جدا انه شركات تروح
للحوكمه بحيث انها تصير داعم للاقتصاد
الوطني بس وش اللي دعاكم في الشركه
تتجهون للحوكمه اكثر هل في شيء معين او
انه عموما قلت لازم هذا مصيرنا لازم يعني
ينتج عشان تظل الشركه قائمه و جهد
عشرات السنين
زين ويجوز من اقتصاد كل الشركات العائليه
يجوز من اقتصاد البلد ونعتبر ان جزء من
اقتصاد البلد انه يجب علينا انه
نسوي الحوكمه فما كان قصدي فيه اشكاليه
ادت للموضوع هذا
اكثر منه ضمان استمراريه
والملاك يبعدون عن الاداره وتصير شركه
قائمه
بدراسه
باقسامه بتصير بطريقه علميه احترافيه
تناسب العصر وشلون نفذتوها يعني طبعا
تدريجيا وهذه
طويل يكون التطوير عشان تنتقل من مؤسسه
فرديه او من ماكينه خياطه الى مؤسسه فرديه
الى شركه ذات مسؤوليه تضامنيه الى شركه
ذات مسؤوليه محدوده ومن تنتقل الى شركه
مغلقه او مساعده هذا هذا خط سير كل شركات
العائليه خلينا نشوفها وصلت
السوق سوان البورصه
السوق الموازي او سوق العام في القران اي
منشاه اليوم يطمح
ولكن ما زال احنا عندنا مرحله تطوير بس
كخطوات يعني غير مساله مؤسسه الى شركه
شركه محدوده الى شركه مغلقه وش الخطوات
اللي اخذتوها داخليا عشان تضمنون الحوكمه
تتم بشكل جيد طبقنا الحوكمه
كامله من سعدكم فيها مثلا طبعا اي شركه
تلجا الى مكاتب استشاريه المجال هذا
بالتطويل
تروح للانظمه عالميه بالمحاسبه
عشان تطور اعمالك تشتغل على موضوع الاي ار
بي او
الخدمه ما بعد البيع او سي ار ام
خدمات العملاء بحيث انه تشتغل كذلك على
الادارات تاسس الادارات الاداره محاسبه
والمراجعه هو التسويق والمبيعات
والمشتريات اداره تصير الهيكله كامله
تطبق المعايير يصير فيها
[موسيقى]
ايداع الميزانيات وزاره التجاره كامله او
تصير مجلس اداره
يكون في توصيات ومحاضر كل ثلاثه شهور من
الشركاء
كذلك
تودع بوزاره التجاره وايش ابرز التحديات
اللي واجهتوها كعائله في التحول هذا
هل كان في بتغير طريقه الشغل بشكل كبير
بابرز التحدي هي المالك نفسه والملاك نفسه
عشان يقتنع يسمونه الاونر اول تحدي الاونر
المالك لازم يقتنع بالتحول لانه
يفك التحكم
وهذه لما التحكم
بالنسبه لهم فكيف انتوا الاخوان اقتنعتوا
ماسك
الفلوس بيده يسكر بقفل الدكان والفلوس
بمخواته كيف ينتقل المراحل المتقدمه انه
ما يشوف
السؤال الحوادث او
القصص التي تحصل بالسوق لما يروح المؤسسين
نهار شركه تلقى عمره 60 سبعين سنه 50 40
سنه تنهار وكثير من القصص اللي صارت لذلك
علشان تجنب هذا لانه الحين الجيل الثالث
ان الجيل
الثاني
الوالد مؤسسه ومن حنا انا واخواني الجيل
الثاني الجيل الثالث
لازم يكون على يطلع على الحوكمه
يعني اسهم وخلاص تنتهي المساله في برضو
الاثنين يتحولت مع الوقت غير الخطوات اللي
ذكرتها سابقا من مؤسسه الشركه الى شركه
مساهمه تحولت ايضا تحت عده شركات وش الفكر
اللي صارت هنا طبعا الفكره هي كالتالي
سوينا براندات تملك هالشركه
بسلع معينه
فابرز براند عندنا وتحته حوالي الفين منتج
اللي شركه
خارج السعوديه
هي معنيه بتطوير المنتجات
وتطويرها ولو سبب فصل يعني البراندات الى
الشركات المستقله تعرف لابد يكون عندك
اكثر من براند كل البراندي يعني تخصص
بمجال معين
ثانيا انه يكون تسجيل دولي
يعني البراندات
نملكها مسجله دوليا الحين بس يتم ضمن شركه
اسناني ليش
كيان واداره مستقله لا لان السنيدي هنا
محليين يعني او دولين
البراندات سجلت عالميه الاكثر من دوله بس
بالقرارات السعوديه
في السؤال الاختم في اعاده ضيوفنا اللي هو
لو برجع بك الزمن لاول يوم
البزنس
وشنبها وش مثلا
ايا كانت
من الله سبحانه وتعالى ولا اشوف انه في
اخطاء
لابد الاخطاء ضروري
في العقبات
شي يصير لكن
سر النجاح توكل على الله سبحانه وتعالى
دعاء الوالدين والاخلاص والصدق مع
الشركاء الاخوان
نشتغل بقلب رجل واحد
مختلف عليها بس هل مثلا طولت في بريده تحس
انه المفروض تطلع بدري الرياض ولا مثلا في
مشاكل معينه في التصنيع والتطوير تمنيت
انك ما اتكلم انه تحسف عليها كثر ما تقول
والله لو رجعت بالزمن بنفس المعلومات ونفس
الخبره هذه الاشياء بشكل مختلف هي الحاجه
الوحيده انه التاخر بالحوكمه
تنطلق من بعدها تصير سهله للاداره والشغل
فكان قبلها الموضوع مرتبط
باداره معينه اذا لم يتوجه الى حوكمه
وادارها مفتوحه
ما فيه قدره السيطره والتوسع لما تتجه الى
الطريقه العلميه
تصير سهل عندك التوسع وخذ القرارات
السريعه
وفيها الاداره التنفيذيه تنفذ بكل سهوله
حسب توجيهات مجلس الاداره فالحوكمه عالجت
البطء وكنت تتمنى لو صارت مهمه جميل الله
يعطيك العافيه ابو حمد الله علوم زياده ان
شاء الله بعد التسجيل
قبل ما تقفل الحلقه اتمنى اذا عجبتك
تشاركها مع اللي حولك وتقيمها بتقييم
ايجابي سواء في اليوتيوب او في ايتونز
واذا كان عندكم ملاحظات عنها
سواء على ايميل البرنامج سوالف ثمانيه او
حتى على حسابي في تويتر ات دبيان شكرا
لمتابعتكم وشكرا لعبد الملك ال سعيد في
اعداد الحلقه ياسر الغانم في اداره
التصوير بالاضاءه غالب محمد ومساعده وياسر
في الاخراج الابداعي وهاب موسى في الاخراج
الفني مجد القرشي في الهندسه الصوتيه عبد
العزيز المزي في التحرير برامج بيبان في
التجهيز عبد المجيد عمر عبد الله بن
الفقيه محمد عبد العزيز او في الانتاج
التنفيذي رزاند هيثم هذا سوالف بزنس احد
منتجات شركه ثمانيه للنشر والتوزيع
[موسيقى]